as coronavirus spread across the country
so did lies and conspiracy theories
about its cause and possible treatments
misinformation shared widely on social
media and messenger services included
the false claim that Rossum soup which
is made from herbs can cure kovat 19
hopes that cocaine kills coronavirus and
the false theory linking the 5g Network
to the spread of the virus that led to
arson attacks on phone masks this one in
Birmingham was set on fire in April and
telecommunication workers were targeted
outside the corona virus is spreading
Wuhan China they pop 10,000 Elysee and
occur and it people started getting sick
the first Dave Snowden heard about the
conspiracy theory was when two men
knocked on the door of his van
away in the window down the mediator
says are you working on the 5g Network
no you want anything to do with 5g mass
no and then he said you best not be
because there'll be trouble you know
strong language
kick the door of the van and then lock
the mirror out the side the side door
got in the car sped off and I thought
what was all that about even though
they're false theories can spread
rapidly
where does misinformation come from
state-backed media agencies in Russia
and China and their goal is just to
present present miss information about
how their governments are dealing with a
crisis some false claims have been
repeated by world leaders
I see the disinfectant weird knocks it
out in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection in Donald Trump later said
he was being sarcastic
MPs have found misinformation can cause
serious harm we've heard from health
care workers on the front line who have
reported quite serious incidents of
people you've ingested bleach and other
chemicals the government says it will
introduce legislation and is working
closely with social media platforms to
help remove incorrect claims that could
endanger people's health Becky Johnson
Sky News